this educational video brought to you by
lab roots will focus on the Nobel Prize
its history and interesting facts about
the prizes lab roots is the leading
professional networking website designed
to connect the scientific world
leveraging a myriad of unique features
hoping users discover meaningful
collaborations across geographic
boundaries and fields of expertise
providing educational tools such as
webcasts are part of lab roots ongoing
effort to help science and technology
professionals better communicate and
disseminate information among each other
effectively educating users on the
latest discoveries and innovations in
their area of expertise on November 27
1895 Alfred Nobel signed his last will
and testament giving the largest share
of his fortune to a series of prizes in
physics chemistry Physiology or medicine
literature and peace the Nobel prizes
Alfred Nobel was the inventor of
dynamite and holder of 355 patents he
was a Swedish chemist inventor engineer
entrepreneur businessman author and
pacifist Alfred Nobel's last will and
testament left most of his fortune to be
used to invest fun and endow what is
today known as the Nobel prizes these
prizes are awarded to those who during
the preceding year shall have conferred
the greatest benefit on mankind the
awards were to specifically be
distributed equally and without
discrimination in the following areas
physics discovery or invention Chemical
discovery or improvement discovery in
Physiology or medicine outstanding work
of literature in an ideal direction and
work of peace there are always two Nobel
ceremonies held one for the Peace Prize
in Oslo and one for the five other prize
categories in Stockholm prize founder
Alfred Nobel wanted it that way for
reasons that he kept to himself
the oldest of this year's laureates is
physics winner Peter Higgs aged 84 the
youngest is 57 year old medicine winner
thomas suedhof the oldest winner in
Nobel history was Leonid Hurwitz who
accepted the economics award at age 90
the youngest was Lawrence Bragg who was
just 25 years old when he collected the
physics award in 1915 the prize winners
receive eight million in Swedish kronor
for each award category that's about 1.2
million dollars the laureates also
receive a gold medal and a diploma there
have been 94 Nobel Peace Prizes handed
out since 1901 no award was given on 19
occasions including during the first and
second world wars the Nobel committee's
keep their deliberations secret for 50
years so we'll have to wait until 2063
to find out who beside the winners was
nominated for the 2013 awards the awards
for 2013 were in economics Eugene fama
and Lars Peter Hansen of the University
of Chicago and Robert Shiller of Yale
University who were honored for
developing new methods to study trends
in asset markets showing that it is
difficult to predict whether stock or
bond prices will go up or down in the
short term but over periods of three
years or more it is possible the nobel
peace prize went to the organization for
the prohibition of chemical weapons the
investigation and enforcement arm for a
1997 treaty banning the use of chemical
weapons based in the hague netherlands
the global chemical weapons watchdog
deploys teams worldwide to identify
whether all 190 nations that have signed
the treaty are disclosing all chemical
weapons stocks and if possessing them
destroying both the weapons and their
manufacturing sites the nobel prize in
literature was given to canadian author
alice munro hailed by the award-giving
swedish academy as a master of the
contemporary short story known as
canada's check off for her astute
unflinching and compassionate depiction
of seemingly unremarkable lives in
chemistry three scientists martin
karplus of the university of strasbourg
france
Harvard University Michael webbot of the
stanford university school of medicine
and rea Warshaw of the University of
Southern California in Los Angeles one
for developing computer models that can
predict chemical reactions for use in
creating new drugs and other tasks in
physics Peter Higgs of Britain and
Francois angle air of Belgium were
chosen for their 1964 theory advanced
independently of each other about how
subatomic particles get their mass their
theory made headlines last year when the
CERN laboratory in Geneva confirmed it
by discovering the so-called Higgs
particle the nobel prize in medicine was
awarded to americans james e Rothman of
Yale University and Randy W schekman of
the University of California at Berkeley
and german-american dr. Thomas C suit
off of the stanford university school of
medicine for their breakthroughs in
understanding how key substances move
within a cell they developed better
understanding of vesicles tiny bubbles
that deliver their cargo within a cell
to the right place at the right time
disturbances in that delivery system can
lead to neurological disorders diabetes
or immunological disorders the Nobel
Prize is an honor that only few are
awarded but their far-reaching gains in
knowledge and breakthroughs in science
literature economics and peace benefit
us all
you